this is it I'm going on a date with Eric
Andre
so what's up chug that one it's time for
you to chug yeah why chug chug chug chug
chug chug chug chug to baby boy I'm
really excited to go on a date with Eric
Andre I think he's a really unique guy
what's the farthest you ever got you a
Jew it's 69 I don't know a goddamn thing
about Keith yeah that's pretty good
do you like me I like you a lot better
[Music]
I got you I got you Thanks now can I eat
these before the meal comes out I mean
it's it's up to you Eric whatever you
want to do
how are you have wet I wanna get my
blood cheeks on the web I don't want to
start out the day like now we need to
get to know just annotate with use it up
okay
you're making me nervous I'm nervous
well I got Ebola and that is concerning
how do you feel about that night
concerned and I'm gonna fill you up
don't fill me up with my virus to the
top I'm excited to just sort of like let
our emotions flow and get to know each
other and who knows maybe we fall in
love I have a very tiny penis I have a
micropenis okay looks like a second
belly but I don't think that's true yeah
yeah I mean I don't think that a measure
of a man should be measured by the
measure of his penis well wait until you
see my dish because it is embarrassing
I hope that we connect on a really deep
level and I hope that he can see in me
what I think is valuable about me as a
partner I even planned anything romantic
for keys I am unprepared I am very
nervous it's time for you to chug yeah
why Chuck chug chug chug chug chug chug
we're halfway through the date right out
to baby boy chug chug chug much drunker
than I thought I'd be here waiter is up
but I think the base point I'm not
checking it write this like a look after
I have anymore
Aaron I think he likes me I think we're
actually connecting as people 60 seconds
on the clock and I finished this we're
gonna have two and three dude what chug
chug chug chug chug
he thinks he has the upper hand he does
you know this restaurant I would figure
it would have a better presentation for
people dining in you don't well we're
we're yeah it's not we're obviously at a
different place you're slurring your
words it's starting to worry me right
why would it worry you fill up the wine
please thank you
correct this isn't going how I wanted it
to go I think I don't know I just never
know where I stand with you oh I drink a
lot of wine he kept insisting that I
drink wine and I wanted to prove to him
that I was the kind of person he wanted
to be with tell me about your mom my mom
is great I'm cool
did she ever sing you a song did you
remember could you sing it I swear to
god her leg is up my bum when I would
cry when I was little she used to sing
me oh my little boy Ken Boykin no my
little boy Ken smokin no my little hos
my Ken Boykin boy Ken wick and Lincoln
and she was just freestyle Yiddish
Boykin means a little boy but he's sang
the song that his mom sang to him you
were a music major you played bass you
switched out of it gave it up I was a
French more major I gave it up let's see
you play for a drawer Patrick can I have
my french horn please I did not know
that that was gonna happen like that I'm
gonna qualify this performance with the
fact that I haven't played in seven
years so I brought out the horns
I didn't have anything prepared but I
just let my emotion push me through what
I would play for him
[Music]
[Music]
not terrible I think I love Keith you
want to get out of here
yes desperately I know that you get hurt
a lot on your show thank you you break
the center but now where you about to
ensure the massages yeah but you wanted
to be organic
yeah it's okay it's a surprise yeah why
don't we put so we're gonna get massages
we're gonna keep talking [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] seen me before before I'm a
[ __ ] sassy little Cathy in a massage
I tried to dig deep into who he was
because so often interviewers ask the
surface level questions and I wanted to
really penetrate him I wanted to really
penetrate him I really wanted to
penetrate him are you happy
oh yeah you're the estimate I know but
like if you're really happy and why are
you always trying to [ __ ] the people you
think that's a sign of asset and the
breath resisting me I don't know if you
need to take down other people I don't I
would take down anybody I'm kind of up
with people yeah yeah how do you do that
I made people laugh there was a moment
where we very clearly were one person I
fell in love with Keith
do you see a future with me yes at the
end of the day I wanted a chance to
break away I was wondering if you and I
could maybe get away from the cameras
for a second and just talk yeah hey man
I just want to say that I I had a really
good time at the Eric please come here
come here just hug me just hug me you
could tell by the way he was pacing back
and forth he was really nervous because
he wanted this to work Eric Eric you
can't keep walking over there and I
really wanted to deploy this will never
work this will never work
don't hit me in the dick please
this will never work you can't try to
seduce me like that at the end of the
video you know we shared a kiss
[Music]
I know that you don't want to stand and
I don't want this to end but it has to
you're busy I'm busy the two of us
really bonded and I really think that
people know now what it's like today
they're a confident and I'm really lucky
I'm really lucky
all right
that was the best damn kissing my wife
I'll miss you forever at gondry until
next time
[Music]
[Music]